[Musik]
ich bin immer glücklich geschäft kommen
und daher eigentlich besser erreichen
können was sie was sie geplant haben
genug sein plus mitbringen und gehen
sogar für ihre wissenschaftliche arbeit
und alles ein wahnsinn
es geht stürmisch zu und her im
südpolarmeer und auf dem internationalen
forschungsschiff nur eine ruhten sich
selbst wie der südpol
wer ist diese schweizerin um das
herauszufinden bin ich vier wochen mit
dir ins boot gestiegen
[Musik]
kapstadt zwei wochen zuvor
es ist mitte dezember als sich daniel
schweren herzens von ihrer familie
verabschiedet
vorfreude vermischt sich mit
abschiedsschmerz die letzten gemeinsamen
momente
[Applaus]
familie roth lebt in südafrika von hier
aus hat die dreifache mutter die
internationale expedition über ein jahr
lang vorbereitet und jetzt ist es soweit
mama fährt ins land der pinguine
mit auf die reise kommt auch ein großer
glücksbringer in die kinder für mama
gemalt haben
zum ersten mal überhaupt ist die familie
für so lange zeit getrennt
[Musik]
das forschungsschiff liegt ab und wird
in 88 tagen wieder hier in kapstadt
zurück erwartet
[Musik]
die akademik technik oft nimmt kurs
richtung süden
ihr ziel ist nicht der südpol sondern
dass mehr drumherum
noch nie ist ein forschungsschiff in
einer saison rund um den antarktischen
kontinent gefahren
die ersten tage verlaufen ruhig wir
lieben uns ein an bord daniel zeigt mir
ihre kabine
sie teilt sie mit einer forscherin die
fast rund um die nur bei ihren geräten
ist einfach ist aber es funktioniert und
hat viel heißes wasser für duschen und
vierteilen zu zweit so ganz am anfang
haben wir entschieden müssen wir zuerst
nach oben geht
im endeffekt bin ich oben gelandet und
da geblieben weil es eigentlich nicht so
schlimm war sie allemal gesagt haben
dass man viel mehr sie krank ist und ab
und zu am morgen stehe ich auf und ich
schaue als erstes raus wie es aussieht
dabei achtet sie immer darauf ob
forschungsarbeiten im gange sind
denn sie ist für deren koordination
verantwortlich für die entnahme von
tiefenwasser proben muss das schiff
mehrere stunden stoppen ziel
schleppnetze im einsatz muss das schiff
unterschiedlich schnell fahren
jeder forscher hat also andere ansprüche
an schiff und besatzung
je besser die koordination desto mehr
proben können die forscher sammeln
nein
land in sicht nach fünf tagen erreichen
wir die prinz edward insel südafrika und
erhält hier eine forschungsstation und
dort wollen jetzt alle hin
die station ist ausgangspunkt für das
sammeln von proben an land hochbetrieb
auf dem hell idec bis auch der letzte
forscher aus geflogen ist
auf dem schiff kehrt ruhe ein gedränge
herrscht nur noch im expedition spiro
denn nur hier gibt es internet die
einzige verbindung zur außenwelt
gemeinsam mit dem chef wissenschaftler
david wollten plant daniel bereits die
rückflüge es eilt schlechtwetter ist
angesagt diesmal war die
schlechtwetterfront schneller als die
expeditionsleiter
die turbulenzen werden immer stärker und
eine russische forschergruppe ist noch
drüben auf der insel zwei stunden dann
wird es dunkel der chef pilot stellt den
flugbetrieb ein
noch gibt sich die expeditionsleiter
gelassen hat organisiert die sind nur 20
minuten entfernt von der station also
sie werden zu fuß noch lange bevor es
nachts ist zurück sei beruhigt gehen wir
alle ins bett obwohl der funkkontakt zu
den russischen forschern abgebrochen ist
und so ahnt niemand auf dem schiff das
die russen nie in der forschungsstation
angekommen sind
erst im morgengrauen wird mir klar dass
etwas nicht stimmt daniel ist äußerst
besorgt noch immer hat sie keinen
kontakt zu den russen
[Musik]
die piloten sollen jetzt die insel nach
den vermissten absuchen
[Musik]
die russen finden um zurück aufs schiff
fliegen das ist ein guter plan aber auch
gelingt
[Musik]
banges warten auf der brücke noch immer
haben die piloten die vermissten nicht
entdeckt
[Musik]
dann endlich die helikopter sind zurück
und zwar mit den drei vermissten russen
durchfroren bis auf die knochen
vorher sollten
auch die geologin anna ist erleichtert
die gruppe hat sich in dichten nebel
verirrt wusste nicht mehr weiter und hat
die ganze nacht versucht das schiff per
funk zu erreichen
[Musik]
jugendforscher alexander kann kaum
sprechen
bei wind und eis legen mussten sie unter
freiem himmel übernachten aber zum glück
haben sie keine erfrierungen
die erleichterung bei allen ist groß
dass der wenige kontakt die tatsache
dass ihr radio funkgerät zum teil nicht
funktioniert hat weil sie auf der
anderen seite des bergs waren und sich
einfach nicht melden konnten dass es
ihnen gut
es ist weihnachten
wir haben sind weit weg von unseren
liebsten doch daniel hat vorgesorgt
jeder an bord musste ihren geschenk
abgeben
diese geschenke verteilt sie jetzt neu
unter den expeditionsteilnehmern
[Gelächter]
ja wie es beim wichteln so ist nicht
alle geschenke passen wie
maßgeschneidert
auch an die küchenmannschaft hat die
waadtländerin gedacht bei ihr geht
wirklich niemand vergessen
[Musik]
während daniel sich hier an bord um alle
und alles kümmert müssen ihre kinder zu
hause erstmals ohne mama weihnachten
feiern
denkt sie oft daran intensiv geschlossen
also man man sitzt nicht sehr viel rum
und überlegte und was machen die und wie
geht es denen im moment und so und ab
und zu eben bei gewissen
schlüsselmomenten
dann muss man sich melden und das ist
wichtig für eine sich zu melden
aber da ich weiß dass es in bestens geht
und dass ich regelmäßig nachrichten gäbe
und erhalte eigentlich bin ich recht
gelassen vielleicht zu sehr ich weiß es
nicht
unser schiff fährt weiter immer weiter
durch das südpolarmeer die sturm
reichste gegend der welt
und endlich darf ich meinen ersten
richtigen sturm erleben
genau so habe ich mir das vorgestellt
[Musik]
daniel hat uns davor gewarnt bei sturm
an deck zu gehen
[Musik]
aber die chance ist einfach zu
verlockend gerade jetzt ein paar
eindrückliche sturm bilder zu drehen
aber obacht jetzt heißt es fersengeld
geben
und ja jetzt weiß auch die reporter
landratte warum bei sturm alle drinnen
bleiben müssen
auch hier ist alles in bewegung
das bild von admiral technik oft genauso
wie die türen uns eine kamera am 31
dezember kommt wieder land in sicht
es ist morgens um sechs noch riss der
wind zu stark
daniel macht sich trotzdem schon mal
bereit mit dabei ihr glücksbringer wie
wir die kinder gemalt haben
auf jeder insel will daniel ihn
fotografieren damit die kinder sehen wo
er schon überall war daniel muss immer
als erste fliegen denn erst wenn sie mit
den behörden die einreise formalitäten
geklärt hat erst dann dürfen auch die
forscher die insel betreten
daniel ist richtig gut gelaunt heute
morgen
der wind hat in keiner weise
nachgelassen der helikopter ist ein
fliegender schüttel becher und ich hab
so richtig schiss als einziger alle
anderen bleiben cool wie eis
polarforscher eben nach zehn langen
minuten erreichen wir endlich die
französische forschungsstation
kaum gelandet beginnen die verhandlungen
mit den behörden
sie wollen genau wissen was wir vorhaben
denn die iju opposition ist streng
geschützt
die erste hürde ist genommen daniel
kümmert sich jetzt um die
passformalitäten während der
chefwissenschaftler wollten aus schiff
zurück fliegt ja es ist kaum zu
übersehen diese insel ist französisches
territorium
hier waren noch präsident und marian
über recht und ordnung aber noch nie
musste der chef die distrikt so viele
pässe bearbeiten und jeder pass braucht
drei stempel
das dauert ewig also greift erst daniel
und dann wir beide dem französischen
staat unter die arme
und so kommt es dass am letzten tag im
jahre des herrn zwei schweizer bürger
teilzeitmitarbeiter in einem
französischen pass büro werden am ende
der welt scheint alles möglich
gewinnt ist so heftig dass keine handys
mehr fliegen
[Musik]
wir sitzen also fest daniel nutzt die
gelegenheit um ihren kindern einen von
silvester zu wünschen und ich um mich
ein bisschen um zu sehen
unwirtlich windig trostlos
so sieht es hier aus
meine rechnung aber habe ich ohne den
wirt gemacht
[Musik]
erst gewöhnen
margret irische spezialitäten viel
gemüse und dazu ein oder vielleicht gar
zwei gläschen wein und nach dem essen
eine kleine verdauungs party im
ehemaligen gewächshaus bei über 20 grad
reporter herz was willst du mehr auch
wenn mich die szene wie hier schon
reichlich so real denkt
[Musik]
daniel will er noch nicht feiern sie hat
ein ziel vor augen und zum ersten mal
auf dieser expedition auch die zeit um
dieses ziel zu besuchen
mehr
schon immer wollte daniel freilebende
pinguine sehen und die igeler position
ist unter wissenschaftlern berühmt für
ihre pinguinkolonie
unglaublich faszinierend ist der anblick
auch für mich pinguine habe ich bisher
nur im zoo gesehen und beim feder
wechseln noch gar nie an land kommen die
pinguine nur fürs brüten erklärt uns der
forscher und die brut pflichten die
nehmen herr und frau pinguin gemeinsam
war daniel gefällt die idee des
gemeinsamen brütens ausgesprochen gut
[Musik]
unterm bett
wir können uns kaum satt sehen an diesem
kreißsaal an dieser maternité für
pinguine
es gibt ein linker ist doch es ist
unglaublich so eine dichte und anzahl
und so ungestört ist beeindruckend
wirklich gut
[Musik]
zurück in der station geht es jetzt noch
den glücksbringer zu fotografieren
keine leichte aufgabe bei solchen
verhältnissen
[Musik]
wenn
das hat ja schon ganz gut geklappt
und plötzlich heißt es unser helles
zurück trotz starkem wind und
heimtückischen böen
die piloten wollen uns für die
silvesterfeier unbedingt zurück auf dem
schiff haben wir machen sie damit
überhaupt keine freude
und schon gar nicht mit diesem
mitgebrachten sicherheits anzug im
teletubbie look zusammen gespielt wie
ein post päckli habe ich bestimmt noch
mehr flugangst
[Musik]
doch searchers gute laune ist ansteckend
und alle außer mir scheinen den rückflug
zu genießen
für daniel und mich ist dies der letzte
flug auf dieser expedition
wir beide werden das schiff nach vier
wochen in australien verlassen
das schiff aber wird weiter ziehen rund
um das ganze südpolarmeer herum bis es
wieder kurs auf südafrika nimmt
[Musik]
zwei monate später die akademik technik
aufläuft nach 88 tagen tatsächlich
wieder in kapstadt ein
daniel hat von südafrikas die expedition
betreut sie hat mit regierungen und all
den beteiligten instituten verhandelt
und jetzt
sie kann es kaum erwarten ihre polar
familie endlich wieder in die arme zu
schließen und der erste auf den sie
trifft ist helikopterpilot jetzt mit
bart und dann natürlich
chefwissenschaftler morton ihr partner
in der expeditionsleiter
daniel zieht es jetzt weiter aufs schiff
dort will sie unbedingt etwas in empfang
nehmen
ok jetzt beantworten telefonisch im
expedition spiro wollten übergibt ihr
feierlich den glücksbringer der ist
nämlich rund um den ganzen südpol
gefahren und wollten hat dafür gesorgt
dass er auf jeder insel fotografiert
wurde
für daniel sind nun fast zwei jahre
harter arbeit zu ende gegangen
das bisher größte abenteuer in ihrem
leben
was es bedeutet als wir angefangen haben
und als ich da reingerutscht bin ich
glaube die kinder werden viel später
realisieren was es bedeutet das erzählen
zu können meine mami war da und sie hat
das gemacht und ich konnte das
miterleben und sie kennen diese länder
sie kennen die tiere sie verstehen von
leidenschaft und wie man arbeiten kann
eigentlich unglaublich schön
[Musik]